that would be the way you know it's
somebody with enough charisma you know
could pull it off you know get people to
get behind it that's really all it would
take is people getting behind it yeah
but the problem is there's so many
people that just we're seeing this with
politics right like I'm fascinated by
these Cavanagh hearings like a watch
little clips of it before I just have to
tune out and talk about Mary talked
about [ __ ] I mean I don't know what
that dude did or what he didn't do but I
think what's happening is more than that
what's happening is first of all he's
involved with he was a big part of the
Patriot Act he was you know he's
involved in some some issues that a lot
of people are very concerned with in
terms of like how his position is stance
on privacy and on rights and absolutely
yeah
there's more to it than just did you
[ __ ] with someone in high school did you
sexually assault someone did you do that
when you're 18 did you do you remember
like there's more to it than that
there's there's like they don't want
that guy in there and then you're seeing
all the people that want to pretend that
he's the best guy ever and all the
people it's crazy yeah it's fascinating
it's really fascinating it's fascinating
to watch this is essentially like a less
like the the clients Thomas hearings
from was it like the 1980s I believe
Clarence Thomas I feel like that was
eight 80s early 90s
yeah somewhere around there Clarence
Thomas that was like with Anita Hill or
he had sexually harassed her they were
working together and she came on
whatever coke or something do you know
that he's now the longest-running member
of the Supreme Court he's he's now been
in the Supreme Court longer I think I
read that check make sure that's true
isn't gru skater kids Bader Ginsburg has
she be on their longest surfing 26 years
as of October 4th well yeah crazy crazy
yeah so it didn't work
Anita's hell's out there then with the
memory of Cuba carrots on coke you know
and a movie now an HBO movie not too
long ago oh yeah did you watch it I saw
it was was it okay it was pretty good
movie
just you know we live through it so it's
like it's like whenever I see movies
about like the OJ trial or something I'm
like no I saw that we saw it live like
set